>>> KANYE WEST IS UPPING HIS
BIZARRE ANSEMITIC TIRADE.
NOW AISING ADOLF HITLER AND
POSTING IMAG THAT SURPASS ELON
MUSK'S APPARENT NEW TOLERANCE
FOR HATE SPEECH ON HIS RECENTLY
ACQUIRED TWITTER.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD HAS BEEN
WORKING THIS STORY FOR US.
TO STAY THAT KANYE WEST'S WORDS
ARE BEYOND THE PALE, THAT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
>> SO OUTRAGEOUS.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE WHAT KANYE
WEST CAN DO TO TOP ALL OF THIS.
ANTIHATE GROUPS SENDING SERIOUS
WARNINGS ABOUT THE POSSIBLE
CONSEQUENCES OF WEST'S LATEST
ACTIONS.
>> Reporter: KANYE WEST BRAZEN
ANTISEMITISM IS ROLLING ON
UNABATED.
DESPITE LOSING DEALS WITH
ADIDAS, THE GAP, VOGUE AND OTHER
CORPORATIONS OVER HIS RECENT
DEFCON THREE TWEET.
WEST, APPEARING IN AN ODD BLACK
MASK ON INFOWARS, A SHOW HOSTED
BY CONSPIRACY THEORIST ALEX
JONES, BRAISING ADOLF HITTER.
>> I SAY GOOD THINGS ABOUT
HITLER.
I'M DONE WITH THE
CLASSIFICATIONS.
EVERY HUMAN BEING HAS SOMETHING
OF VALUE THEY BROUGHT TO THE
TABLE.
ESPECIALLY HITLER.
THERE IS A LOT OF THINGS THAT I
LOVE ABOUT HITLER.
A LOT OF THINGS.
>> Reporter: WEST HAS APPARENTLY
JUMPED SO FAR OFF THE DEEP END
HE IS TOO OUTRAGEOUS FOR ELON
MUSK'S NEW WILD WEST TWITTER.
HE HAS HAD HIS ACCOUNT SUS
SWENDED BY TWITTER.
CNN COULDN'T CONFIRM WHICH
SPECIFIC TWEET, WEST TWEETED A
STAR OF DAVID WITH A SWASTIKA
INSIDE AND MUSK TWEETED I TRIED
MY BEST, DESPITE THAT, HE AGAIN
VIOLATED OUR RULE AGAINST
INCITEMENT OF TO VIOLENCE.
>> WHILE I WANT TO SEE TWITTER
DO MORE TO ADDRESS INTOLERANCE
AND INCITEMENT OF ON THE
PLATFORM, I'M GLAD THEY HAVE
TAKEN DOWN KANYE'S ACCOUNT.
>> Reporter: WHY SHOULD WE CARE
ABOUT THE RANTS OF AN OSTRACIZED
ARTIST LIKE WEST.
HE IS HAS 30 MILLION FOLLOWSER
ON TWITTER.
>> HE HAS A LOT OF CULL KMURL
CACHET.
HIS NAME IS STILL, YOU KNOW,
KNOWN AROUND THE WORLD.
SO WHEN SOMEONE LIKE THAT IS
POPULARIZING ANTISEMITISM, WE'VE
ALL GOT A PROBLEM.
>> Reporter: BUT IF YOU THINK
ELON MUSK HAS RIDDEN IN TO SAVE
SOCIAL MEDIA FROM THE LIKES OF
KANYE WEST, THINK AGAIN.
DESPITE MUSK'S RECENT
DECLARATION THAT HATE SPEECH HAD
BEEN REDUCED ON TWITTER, THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE AND
CENTER FOR COUNTERING DIGITAL
HATE HAVE NEW REPORTS SAYING THE
VOLUME OF HATE SPEECH ON TWITTER
HAS WRIZEN DRAMATICALLY UNDER
MUSK'S LEADERSHIP.
>> HE TOOK OVER A PLATFORM THAT
WAS WORKING OKAY AND FIRST OF
ALL FIRED ALL THE PEOPLE WHOSE
JOB IT WAS TO CLEAN THESE THINGS
UP AND SECOND HE PUT UP THE BAT
SIGNAL SAYING WE'RE OPEN TO
BUSINESS TO RACISTS, HOMOPHOBES,
TRANS FOLKS AND MISSAGE
JOURNALISTS.
>> THERE IS GENUINE DANGER
BEYOND THE KEYBOARD ANONYMITY OF
SOCIAL MEDIA RANTS.
>> LOOK AT THE RISE IN
TRANSPHOBIC HATRED AND WHAT
HAPPENED IN COLORADO SPRINGS.
>> Reporter: NOW, TWITTER DID
NOT IMMEDIATELY RESPOND TO A
REQUEST FOR COMMENT ON THE
STUDIES SHOWING THERE IS A SURGE
OF HATE SPEECH ON TWITTER.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS TWEETED THAT
THE HOLOCAUST HAPPENED, THAT
HITLER WAS A DEMONIC FIGURE,
POLITICAL LEADERS HAVE